tu connais stéphane monaco battu par
c'est pas la femme de ta vie ah non non
j'ai croisé un jour où d'un ouais
effectivement elle est assez mignonne
mais bon tu sais un problème s'il faut
les moyens
ouais mais bon c'est marrant voilà ça
brille ça pis du social c'est pas
évident quoi tu crois pas non j'y crois
pas je crois pas du tout ce qui compte
pas pourquoi tu sais quel enfin sa
famille deviendraient constantine comme
toi tu crois
ouais on a été aux affaires alors
d'avoir le 26 juin 1989
le prince rainier de monaco fêter ses 40
ans de règne
ouf car ce sont quarante années sauvé in
extremis pour perpétuer le nom des
grimaldi vieille de 700 ans une
prolongation qu'ils doivent tous
écoutaient bien à une vulgaire lingère
de constantine
l'histoire se passe en 1890 en algérie
louis 2
le grand-père de renier y est officier
la blanchisseuse de la caserne ne lui
plaît beaucoup
une petite fille charlotte naîtra de ce
méga fait banal mais l'histoire ne
s'arrête pas là en 1918 on a signé un
traité entre monaco et la france
la france reconnaissait la souveraineté
de monaco est exigée par une clause
dynastique à ce que si jamais le trône
restés vacants et bien la principauté
passé devenez protectorat français
administrée par les alpes-maritimes
or en 1920 la lignée des grimaldi
n'avait plus d'héritier pour garder son
rocher à 50 ans louis ii avait oublié de
se marier
tant pis la fille de la lingère ferait
la faire et on l'a marié on a arrangé un
mariage avec le descendant d'une des
plus illustres familles françaises
les polignac et pierre conte de polignac
a épousé en 1920 la petite princesse
charlotte charlotte souvet ainsi la
principauté de tempérament excentrique
volcanique mal à l'aise sur le rocher
charlotte se montrera pourtant bonne
fille en 1944 elle abdiquera de ses
droits au trône en faveur de l'un de ses
deux enfants
régnier
[Musique]
le feuilleton des grimaldi pouvait
continuer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le traité de 1918 est
toujours en vigueur mais une question se
pose
albert aura-t-il des enfants ou
faudra-t-il trouver d'autres héritiers
pas très loin cette fois ci
alors les grimaldi descente il d'une
enchère de constantine d'abord je vais
demander à ce mail à l'oreille oui de
l'afo de l'intox sans hésitation d'intox
de l'intox étoiles avides de l'intox
ainsi aussi à bon il semble pas trop en
quoi je peux le révéler maintenant tu
m'as dit que c'était de l'intox c'est à
dire c'est assez amusant ma présence ici
les à constantine savoir quels sujets
relation est constante et je pense qu'on
a fait et éventuellement bon ben on va
savoir on va écouter l'expert à toi
phillip et bien qu un tonnerre
d'applaudissements se fassent entendre
jusqu'au rocher de monaco c'est de
l'info allawi
mais vous êtes du même pays bas alors
j'ai des chances alors mais tu as toutes
tes chances et pour ça mais oui elles
sont partout les caméras stéphanie accès
à tout commentaire
un grand
et oui on se met sur aussi on est frais
et aller partout faut préciser aussi
pourquoi leur constante s'en va ça va
notre expert philippe guérin et écoutent
oui thierry c'est de l'info c'est de
l'info et je crois que ça fait pas
vraiment plaisir la principauté de
monaco on n'aime pas vraiment en parler
c'est totalement à bout pourtant on voit
bien les efforts que fait stéphanie
aujourd'hui poursuivre cette filiation
de cette lingère de constantine avec
tous ses efforts en matière de mode il
ya une ligne de maillots de bain une
ligne de vêtements de cuir une ligne de
petites culottes une ligne de
chaussettes pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou